i've been working in the fingerprint
field now for over 20 years although it
can be really intricate and
time-consuming work it is just so
fantastic when you actually make a match
most of us probably think that we've got
a pretty good understanding of the basic
principles of forensic science we binge
on true crime tv series we read and buy
huge numbers of books and obsessively
download true crime podcasts trying to
figure out who'd done it but there are
some things about forensic science that
you will probably only know if you're an
insider
let's start with some basics where does
all the information forensic scientists
needs come from
well everywhere really
in the early 1900s french criminologist
edmund lockhart declared that every
contact leaves a trace
this forms the basis of what is now
called lockhart exchange principle which
says that whatever you interact with you
leave something behind and take
something away
one of the areas of forensic science
where this is particularly applicable is
forensic botany there are around 390 000
different species of plants in the world
each with its own pollen type and when
it comes to crime scenes pollen can
really tell a story it's all around us
it's on the ground
if you walk on soil or vegetation that's
what you pick it up inevitably you pick
it up patricia wiltshire is a forensic
ecologist she uses pollen to help solve
crimes
unlike other forms of evidence pollen
isn't easily washed away it gets into
clothes and it can often be found on
shoes or on the foot pedals in cars
pollen and spores are too small to be
seen by the naked eye so criminals
rarely realize that they have picked
them up at a crime scene pollen and
spores are produced by plants and fungi
they grow in specific places so you know
very well that this plant will grow in
this soil that plant will grow in that
soil and because of that we can predict
where they are from in one particular
case of an attempted murder this man
tried to strangle a girl underneath a
lamppost and he said he hadn't been
there of course but by taking his
clothing apart i showed that he bumped
up against a fence with his left
shoulder that he dragged her through a
hedge that he'd knelt and so on and
because i sampled the crime scene
in detail i could see where bits of his
body had been so i could i could
actually reconstruct what he did at the
time there are other ways in which
nature can help forensic scientists
determine when a crime was committed
insects for example can provide a lot of
information if you know what to look for
as forensic entomologist americ whitaker
explains
when you die your body starts to break
down and decompose
basically straight away and so your body
starts giving off certain odors and
those are very attractive to blow flies
if we can work out how old the larvae
are that are feeding on the body
then we can work out the minimum time
that that person must have been dead the
colder it is the slower the larvae
develop the warmer it is the faster they
develop really the shorter the time span
since the death the more accurate we can
be remember edmund lockhart the french
criminologist we mentioned earlier his
contribution to forensic science didn't
end everything leaves a trace he
developed and contributed to various
methods of forensic analysis including
dactology the study of fingerprints the
interpretation of evidence has changed a
lot since i became a crime scene
examiner 20 years ago
back then if i examined a car whose door
had been broken open to gain entry and
the only evidence i found was a finger
mark on the outside of the driver's door
i could reasonably expect that if the
finger mark was identified for someone
then that person would eventually be
charged with the offence and the case
would go to court however things are now
very different
if the same finger mark was found today
especially in a relatively non-serious
case such as this
there would be a strong likelihood that
it wouldn't go to court and this is
because the crown prosecution service or
cps they need to be satisfied that there
is sufficient evidence to provide a
realistic prospect of conviction their
argument for not prosecuting based on
the finger mark on the outside of the
vehicle might be that anyone could have
walked by and leaned on the vehicle
leaving the mark
in the past defense barristers argued
about who the evidence belonged to but
now they focus on how the evidence got
there could the evidence have been left
by someone other than a person breaking
into the car if there is any possibility
it could be someone else then the cps
tend not to take these cases to court
forensic science is constantly evolving
in the future it's possible that many
crimes will be solved before they've
even been committed as predictive
software will mean that police forces
will be able to anticipate when and
where a crime is likely to take place
and even who is likely to commit it then
there's our microbiome the tiny microbes
in our gut which according to a new
study by harvard can identify us as
individuals just like a fingerprint
despite the rapidly changing world of
forensics linda says there's one thing
that good forensic scientists never
forget that we're dealing with real
people's lives and we need to ensure
that we work in an objective and
unbiased way because if we get it wrong
it's people's liberty that's at stake
thanks for watching if you enjoyed that
be sure to check out these videos next
and if you haven't already hit the
subscribe button and click the bell to
get a notification each time we upload a
new video